saudi arabia is promising to take all
necessary measures to protect itself
after yemen's houthi rebels launched
another attack on its energy facilities
the saudi government has confirmed the
iramku oil plant in dahran was
targeted by a ballistic missile earlier
a drone hit rust hanura ports one of the
world's largest oil shipping ports
saudi officials say they intercepted the
drone and missile attacks
and there was minimal damage but the
houthis say it was
a much bigger assault
the artillery and drone divisions were
able to conduct a wide offensive
in the depths of saudi arabia with 14
drones
and eight ballistic missiles we targeted
aramco in ras
altanura port and other military
facilities in damam
more military sites were targeted in
asera and jazan and the strike was
precise well the saudi coalition
responded to the attacks
[Applause]
by hitting hootie targets in yemen's
capital sana
a residential area was struck and there
are reports of
casualties let's bring in our
correspondent hashem ahabara here in
doha he's covered the war in yemen
extensively so hashem you'll be able to
just explain to us
what is this escalation all about what's
behind these
uh recent attacks that we're seeing well
hala from that statement by the
spokesperson
of the uh of the of the houthi
uh in in yemen he's basically
uh syria he's saying that the armed
forces of the houthis managed to
launch attacks deeper into saudi arabia
now they're targeting they say that they
are targeting
areas in uh vahrehaan
jazan and also in asia and the one in
bahrain is very crucial because it has
one of the
most vital oil installations for
saudi arabia and she's also crucial for
the
supply of oil globally and this explains
why the
price of oil has jumped earlier today as
a reaction to that attack by the houthi
it's a show of force because this is the
second most significant attack by the
houthis
since 2019 when they targeted with
drones
crucial oil facilities in the eastern
part of saudi arabia
knocking off the output production for
for 50 percent of the world output
production for
for day it was similar tactic by the
houthis saying that six years since the
start of the
war launched by saudi arabia united arab
emirates in yemen
the houthis remain strong powerful
gaining ground and able to retaliate
and also target vital areas inside saudi
arabia
and the hashem more globally what would
you say the houthis are trying to
achieve here well we have to remind our
viewers hello that this comes against
the backdrop of a crucial fight which is
underway as we speak
in the uh in the province of mary it's
a stronghold for the internationally
recognized government
of the abdullah sword handy this is
where the saudis have been
maintaining a military presence
providing significant support for the
government of hadi and it's an uh
it is rich in oil the province itself
the houthis have decided to move all the
way from sana'a towards
al-jaff and now to marry to take it over
first of all this is a show force
number two they're saying that they're
gaining ground number three
if they can take it over it will be the
ultimate humiliation for saudi arabia
and for the government of abdullah
abdullah
if they lose marriage it could be the
beginning of the end for the
internationally recognized government
and this explains why now
we're seeing an attempt by all the
parties
to to maintain their presence in matter
and to prevent the healthy takeover
and i think we will see an aggressive
push by the saudis in the upcoming
days to prevent that from uh happening
the battle for narep
could be decisive for the future of
yemen
okay something to keep a very close eye
on hashima habara live from doha thank
you hashem